[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de mode
d'emploi votre émission dédiée à
l'emploi et aux formations
professionnelles
ce numéro sera consacré aux métiers du
commerce tout de suite le sommaire
saint-quentin-en-yvelines premier pôle
commercial du département one nacion
paris ouest ou encore l'espace saint
quentin skywest des centres commerciaux
source d'emplois dans la vente
découverte des secrets pour devenir un
bon vendeur en magasin une boutique
école pour former des jeunes au métier
de vendeur le principe de scola cette
structure a ouvert ses portes au mois de
septembre dans l'espace saint quentin
rend compte dans cette édition avec les
élèves de la première promotion est avec
erwan le gall élu communautaire déléguée
à l'emploi
enfin retrouvé durant l'émission des
offres d'emploi pour la période de noël
dans les centres commerciaux du
territoire riche de ses 2500
établissements commerciaux saint quentin
en yvelines est le premier pôle
commercial du département le commerce
saint-quentinois c'est plus de 2
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
par an trois centres commerciaux majeurs
plaisir les clayes-sous-bois maurepas
coignières et montigny le bretonneux
avec l'espace saint quentin et skywest
ce dernier pôle commercial est composée
de 130 boutiques et 1800 collaborateurs
la plupart sont des vendeurs les détails
sur ce métier dans ce reportage
ça vous regarde à la maison les couleurs
les modèles s'intéresser aux clients
être attentionné avoir le sens du
relationnel des qualités indispensables
pour travailler dans le secteur du
commerce dans cette bijouterie de
l'espace saint quentin la connaissance
des produits peut s'acquérir avec le
temps un bon vendeur ou une bague devant
des salles terriens qui prend du plaisir
à rencontrer l'autre je crois une
personne entre mia une fibre de vendeurs
et qui connaît pas le produit va
apprendre alors ce qu'elle apprenne
assez vite pour pouvoir être à l'aise
voire faire former pour pouvoir donner
du plaisir et en prendre
l'ensemble était vendre des montres des
bijoux en or en argent le quotidien des
employés de cette boutique une
bijouterie spécialisée aussi dans la
réparation
vous l'avez accidenté alors tout va bien
tout est réparable parce que c'est une
chaîne en argent blanc autres enseignes
mais même métier ce magasin
d'accessoires hommes et femmes
chapeau gants châle ou écharpe les
produits sont mises en valeur tout comme
le client même si la vente n'est pas
concrétisée après tout les ventes ne se
concrétise pas parce qu'il ya des gens
qui viennent en repérage mais ça veut
pas dire qu'ils reviendront pas après
c'est le cas de ses deux clientes venus
en repérage il ya une semaine on a après
avec la capuche
c'est pas mal aussi et sinon j'ai avec
les manches finalement elles repartent
avec un plaid le gants assortis et un
châle les deux derniers articles
considérés comme des achats additionnels
ou en fait dans nos têtes faut
automatiquement qu'on sache quel
accessoire peut aller avec
au niveau des tons des couleurs pour
pouvoir proposer aux gens et quand ils
essayent en fait de leur montrer et de
leur présenter sur eux
l'accessoire qui va avec avec 130
boutiques l'espace saint quentin emploie
près de 1800 personnes chaque année
environ 200 recrutements sont réalisés
la période des fêtes de fin d'année est
souvent synonyme de renfort en effectifs
pour les centres commerciaux
la boutique tyra que vous venez de
découvrir dans ce reportage de recherche
une personne pour un contrat à durée
déterminée du 7 au 24 décembre un poste
payé au smic profil recherché souriant
ayant un relationnel agréable pardon
autres offres d'emploi la bijouterie le
donjon présente aussi dans le reportage
souhaite embaucher deux employés aux cdd
en cdd du 1er au 31 décembre un contrat
de 35 heures et un autre de 30 heures de
postes rémunérés au niveau du smic
les candidats doivent être motivées
avoir le sens de l'accueil et de la
clientèle cv et lettre de motivation à
déposer directement au magasin n'hésitez
pas aussi à vous rendre directement dans
les boutiques des différents centres
commerciaux de l'agglomération pour des
vous posez vos cv et vos lettres de
motivation
plusieurs magasins sont à la recherche
d'employés pour la période de noël
c'est une première en ile-de-france le
programme scola été lancée en septembre
à l'espace saint quentin créé par la
fondation des apprentis d'auteuil cette
formation aux métiers du commerce est
destiné aux jeunes
au programme des cours et une mise en
pratique pratique dans un vrai magasin
découverte de cette boutique écoles sur
un montage signé sandrine fonteilles
jours explique on marche dans l'espace
et comme une personne décide de
s'arrêter
tout le monde doit s'arrêter en même
temps des exercices de cohésion de
groupe d' écoute et de postures c'est le
cours de théâtre du programme scola une
formation au métier de vendeur avec un
accompagnement sur le savoir être et sur
la personnalité de chacun des jeunes
leur apprendre par exemple avoir plus
confiance en eux avoir une meilleure
estime deux mètres de la valeur sûre
qu'ils sont c'est hyper important pour
nous qu'ils soient fiers de leur
histoire de leur parcours scolasse est
une boutique école créée par la
fondation des apprentis d'auteuil mise
en place par saint quentin en yvelines
pôle emploi et l'espace saint quentin
une formation de deux mois avec à la clé
un diplôme de vendeur conseil en magasin
reconnu par l'état
nous nous sommes engagés fortement
depuis plusieurs années
dans l'emploi et plus précisément
l'emploi local et l'insertion des jeunes
sans qualification
ils sont quinze jeunes dans cette
première promotion parmi eux à fès 28
ans opticien de formation il souhaite
élargir ses compétences dans le domaine
du commerce
j'ai appris à me connaître surtout aussi
aider en revente
parce que c'est aussi important pour
courant vendeur de savoir se vendre en
fait
au chômage depuis trois mois zineb 22
ans a appris l'existence de scola grâce
à une amie intéressée elle a passé un
entretien et à intégrer la boutique
écoles en formation on apprend des
choses juste génial voilà se connaître
soi même on prend confiance en soi on en
ressort que que meilleur on grandit on
est beaucoup plus mature relation avec
le client stratégie de vente mise en
avant du produit les élèves mettent en
pratique la théorie dans la boutique
ouverte du mardi au samedi
la priorité c'est la posture c'est de
pouvoir être à l'aise avec les clients
et d'aller facilement vers le client
pour pouvoir avancer dans l'acte de
vente
j'ai pu vendre des t-shirts origine ils
sont faits dans le jura le premier gros
jim sinegal moi j'ai vendu c'est pas
possible
non franchement c'est génial surtout
quand on est un peu timide et c'est avec
du coup on se rend compte que là on a
réussi à vendre un produit et on a
réussi à bord d'un client de manière
naturelle et où on se dit mais ça veut
dire que suis capable de tout en fait
finalement trois jeunes sur les quinze
ont déjà été embauchées en cdi avant la
fin officielle de leur formation prévue
le 17 novembre face aux difficultés
rencontrées par les acteurs commerciaux
à trouver de la main d'oeuvre
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accompagne les
entreprises dans leurs recrutements
cela passe notamment par le programme
scola dont l'agglomération est à
l'initiative
elle propose aussi d'autres dispositifs
rencontre avec erwan le gall conseillers
communautaires à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines d'harwanne le
gall avec nous bonjour bonjour
conseiller communautaire délégué à
l'emploi et à
l'insertion professionnelle alors viens
de voir le reportage sur scola comment
vous avez construit ce projet au sein de
l'espace saint quentin alors écoutez
c'est intéressant on fini ici à hans kaï
business des îles il ya exactement un an
le groupe hammerson le groupe hammerson
nous interpelle avec le vice président
en charge du commerce
grigori karassine pour dire écoutez on a
des difficultés de recrutement au niveau
du commerce au niveau des vendeurs
forcément en tant qu'élu à l'emploi ça
m'a interpellé
bon écoutez j'ai dit on va trouver une
solution une semaine après je ramenais
un concept que je suis allé chercher à
paris il ya la fondation d'auteuil
voilà donc les apprentis d'auteuil dont
un concept s'appelle scola et en plus il
avait un partenariat national avec le
groupe hammerson
donc c'est très bien tombé donc ils ont
travaillé de concert 50 a évidemment été
partenaires dès le départ dans ce
concept
donc il ya eu 7 concept d'école
où les jeunes qui sont source hépar 6,25
par les missions locales viennent
s'exercer pendant un durée
il devrait donner et après le concept en
tant que tel c'est que vraiment les
commerçants autour viennent rechercher
est sûre c'est là où il ya une activité
donc on a vraiment été partenaires dès
le départ et c'est quelque chose qui
fonctionne bien et on va continuer
évidemment quand quoi ce concept vous a
intéressé en tant qu'élu à l'emploi
alors moi ce qui m'intéresse en ce
moment parce que depuis bientôt trois
ans du ce et élu on se rend compte que
le format du recrutement et le format en
tant que tel
de l'activité de vente de la
restauration et de plein d'autres
secteurs d'activité on est carencé parce
que on à rester sur des concepts de
recrutement qui sont complètement
obsolète
on a on se doit de revoir un petit peu
le mode de recrutement avec le cv lettre
de motivation
oui il faut le faire pour un certain
niveau pour un niveau de ça il faut
revoir les choses
donc c'était intéressant formats courts
motivation si un an sur signe
les jeunes vont être très motivés et une
fois qu'ils sont motivés et qu'ils sont
bien ciblés ça fonctionne parce que
c'est un format qui leur convient on est
dans une ère où on est de thé rapide
tout doit d'être ému d'apprendre
rapidement et acquérir quelque chose
rapidement ça leur convient après ils
ont un job ils ont un employeur et la de
coups et se stabilise mme et ça
fonctionne
d'ailleurs ce que la demande est montré
dans le sud elles ont démontré le nord
je vous rappelle puisque la en ile de
france on est les premiers à saint
quentin à l'avoir mis en place sur l'île
de france sas et innovant
en quoi les métiers de la vente sont une
source d'opportunités de réinsertion ou
d'insertion professionnelle tout court
pour les jeunes saint quentinois alors
la complexité en ce moment c'est qu'il
ya tellement de la plus d'offres que de
demandes
alors je peux mon temps est trop court
pour vous expliquer dans tous les cas il
est intéressant parce que le jeune il
peut être formé très rapidement
par contre en par contre il y a un
certain nombre d'impératifs qu'il faut
que ça complexifie le besoin voilà la
phase du temps de préparation
la couverture horaire les lieux voilà la
mobilité tous à fond que ce soit au des
freins mais on y arrive on y arrive
voilà nous mois entre président de
skyway 16 25
on a mis en place de nouveaux concepts
on l'a vu dans le reportage la formation
scola c'est certes formé aux métiers de
la vente mais c'est aussi redonner
confiance en soi il ya des coachs
sportifs qui viennent pour des
psychologues aussi pour aussi redonner
confiance en ses jeunes à la foi en la
vie en leurs compétences aussi parce
qu'ils en ont c'est ça aussi ce voilà
c'est retisser du lien social via la
confiance en soi mais vous savez
je ne fais pas que élu jeu c'est un
métier à côté d'une entreprise je fais
plein de choses
le jeune ou moins jeune parce qu'on
parle des jeunes mais il ya ici la 3g
des seniors est ce qu'ils sont et
restent à redonner confiance à quelqu'un
et vous le savez dans votre vie à un
moment où des statuts comme il a fait
des études avant quand vous dites est
faux reprendre confiance et redonner
confiance
c'est aussi ouvrir des clés et des
serrures avec des clés pas magique mais
concrètes et je crois qu'il faut avoir
un langage précis clairs mais les
rassurer
effectivement le coach sportif et le
lien avec le sport est très intéressant
un dernier mot et rhône le gall sur les
autres dispositifs que vous mettez à
disposition des personnes qui
recherchent peut-être des emplois dans
le métier de du commerce alors que je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure
surprendre ce caillou et on on essaie
d'innover
le 20 novembre sur la zone de
paris-ouest coignières meurent pas il y
à une forte demande
pareil dans la vente et dans la
restauration la vie on a inversé on a
fait un job dating mais à l'envers
c'est à dire que ce sont sur des
créneaux de 2 heures 15 heures 17 heures
20 enseignes de ce secteur là qui
ouvrent leurs portes aux jeunes on
sélectionne nuit jeunes par rapport à
des mots clés de motivation qui vont
dans les enseignes avec des micros cv
microsemi compétences clac clac clac une
phrase type et vont rencontrer les chefs
d'entreprise ça c'est innovant et ça ça
va fonctionner on a déjà 160 jeunes qui
sont en lice voilà je crois qu'il faut
inverser les méthodes il faut revoir et
font aussi expliqué avoir un peu de
pédagogie un cachet d'entreprise en
disant ce que vous voulez à kabako
calcul oui c'est bien mais maintenant il
ya d'autres codes au niveau de l' encore
la loi de galles merci beaucoup je
rappelle que vous êtes conseiller
communautaire délégué à l'emploi et à
l'insertion professionnelle
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour un nouveau numéro à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]